y
[Música]
ante el avance de omicron en américa
ecuador decidió enviar a teletrabajo a
la mitad de los funcionarios venezuela
comenzó la dosis de refuerzo en eeuu
aprobaron la tercera dosis para los
menores entre los 12 y los 15 años
en colombia los nuevos enfrentamientos
entre las disidencias de las farc y la
guerrilla de ln dejan al menos 24
personas muertas los grupos se disputan
el control territorial del departamento
de arauca que es fronterizo con
venezuela
en turquía la inflación se disparó a su
punto más alto desde el 2003 cerrando el
2021 con un 36 1% el presidente reyerta
y erdogán sigue siendo blanco de
críticas por sus políticas de mantener
bajas las tasas de interés yendo en
contra de las recomendaciones de los
expertos
bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión de
noticias de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle y es un placer
saludarlos y empezamos en ecuador donde
el 50% de los empleados públicos
volverán al teletrabajo ante el aumento
de contagios además las autoridades
permitieron la dosis de refuerzo para
quienes tengan entre 50 y 59 años la
provincia de guayas que fue el epicentro
al inicio de la pandemia ya comenzó a
registrar un alza considerable de casos
con más de 1.700 semanalmente una cifra
que no se veía desde marzo nuestro
corresponsal en quito- gustavo ortega
tiene más información
comienza el año 2022 en ecuador y se
refuerzan las medidas sanitarias ante el
reporte de casos de kobe 19 el país
andino el 50 por ciento de los
trabajadores de las entidades del sector
público deberán retornar al teletrabajo
mientras el gobierno nacional recomiendo
los gobiernos municipales parroquiales y
al sector privado tomar la misma
decisión
las medidas durarán hasta el 23 de enero
y buscan frenar el acelerado avance de
la variante o micro en algunas ciudades
ya considerado de contagio comunitario
el gobierno busca restringir inclusive
la movilidad de las personas en las
calles y demanda las autoridades exigir
certificado de vacunación para el uso de
transporte público una medida que ya se
aplica para acceder a los servicios no
esenciales para ingresar a comercios
restaurantes y centros comerciales el
rebrote de casos de kobe 19 ha puesto en
alerta al ecuador en algunos hospitales
del país donde los rebrotes ascienden a
más de 9000 casos semanales según cifras
oficiales 'ecuador apura la vacunación
masiva para alcanzar la inmunidad de
rebaño que no pudo alcanzarse y estaba
planificada para finales del año pasado
hasta la fecha se contabiliza el 78 por
ciento de la un mayor de cinco años
vacunada con su dosis completa ya se
inició la vacunación de terceras dosis y
se anunció que en este mes se vacunará a
la población de niños de 4 años buscando
un ocular al 85% de los ciudadanos
residentes en el país el relajamiento
total y las aglomeraciones a causa de
las celebraciones decembrinas son la
causa de repuntes de nuevos contagios en
ecuador y en venezuela ya comenzó la
dosis de refuerzo el ministerio de salud
indicó que la campaña será inicialmente
para inmunizar a médicos y enfermeras
que están en contacto directo con
pacientes diagnosticados con kobe 19
luego llegará el resto de los
trabajadores de la salud
y mientras las cifras de contagio por la
variante omicron siguen creciendo en
eeuu las autoridades sanitarias todavía
se enfrentan a la baja popularidad de la
vacuna en algunos estados conservadores
de hecho pensilvania y particularmente
del condado de cumbria registran récords
en sus tasas de contagios mientras que
las de vacunación son muy bajas hasta
allí llegó un equipo de nuestros
corresponsales
el invierno llegó a johnston pensilvania
y con él la tasa de contagio más alta
desde la aparición del virus en esta
clínica solidaria orosa lidón son con la
directora vigila constantemente el
avance de la pandemia en su ciudad
aquí en johnstown con la crisis del
cómic 19 necesitamos que más gente se
vacune muchos han recibido la inyección
pero aún hay más gente que no la recibió
cada día leo el periódico y encuentro el
nombre de dos o tres personas de nuestro
condado que fallecieron por kobe 19 que
merckle heart of code sin embargo en
esta pequeña clínica de johnston no
falta nada para enfrentarse al virus ni
las dosis de vacuna ni los médicos para
administrarla
mezclo 18 mililitros de solución salina
con la vacuna y luego con cada frasco
para adultos puedo realizar 6 dosis de
vacuna
la doctora que leer es una de nuestros
médicos es una voluntaria y es la más
antigua de diez mil habitantes y menos
del 40 por ciento vacunados las causas
la impopularidad de la vacuna están
identificadas
piensan que otras cosas funcionan mejor
que la vacuna como la hidroxi cloroquina
dicen que la vacuna no fue
suficientemente probada y todo tipo de
cosas así este
mientras empieza un nuevo año marcado
por el cubil 19 en los barrios de
johnston 6 consumidores de cada 10
todavía no están vacunados fue revelado
un acuerdo entre virginia jeffrey y el
agresor sexual jeffrey epstein el
documento demuestra que eps ingle pagó
500 mil dólares en el año 2009 para que
abandonara el caso en el que acusaba de
abuso sexual y de traficarla para el
príncipe andrew de la corona británica
cuando ella aún era una menor de edad el
príncipe ha negado todo señalamientos de
quien lo demandó en 2021 su defensa
asegura que el pacto alcanzado con sting
lo protege sin embargo el nombre del
príncipe no aparece en el acuerdo dado a
conocer este lunes por lo que el litigio
podría ir a juicio entre septiembre y
diciembre de este año
en colombia al menos 24 personas
murieron en medio de los enfrentamientos
entre una disidencia de las farc y la
guerrilla del l en las disputas se dan
en el departamento colombiano de arauca
y en el estado venezolano de apure ambos
comparten fronteras previamente hablamos
con camilo gonzález posso presidente de
la organización colombiana indepaz él
nos explicó cuáles son las afectaciones
en la población civil y cuál es la
importancia de este corredor entre
colombia y venezuela
se habla de más de 24 asesinatos de
personas de civiles pero incluso las
cifras son mayores porque las
autoridades locales hablan de 50
personas desaparecidas y se teme por la
vida de muchas de ellos
desplazamiento están más de 3000
personas en cinco mil si tomamos el
conjunto del departamento de la frontera
en situación de confinamiento de
desplazamiento en la emergencia
humanitaria con combates que se han
venido dando no solamente en las
fronteras sino dentro del territorio
venezolano y también en varios
municipios del lado colombiano
todas esas fronteras son corredores para
tráfico de armas y también son formas de
eludir
el enfrentamiento de buscar refugios
cuando hay acciones ofensivas de la
fuerza pública en colombia pero también
el tráfico de drogas todo tipo de
tráfico además también hay intereses
sobre recursos mineros en el arco minero
venezolano es decir los grupos
los colombianos necesitan unas economías
muy poderosas para poder desarrollar sus
actividades y eso lo hacen también en
territorio venezolano entonces está
todos los negocios ilícitos rentas y
control de la población la inflación en
turquía se disparó en diciembre en medio
de la crisis económica en ese mes los
precios al consumidor subieron casi un
14% por lo que la inflación anual se
ubicó en un 36,1 por ciento la cifra más
alta en casi dos décadas
la tasa de inflación anual de turquía
está en su nivel más alto en los 19 años
que recep tayip erdogán ha gobernado el
aumento de los precios está sacudiendo a
los consumidores la gente tiene que
pensar dos veces antes de comprar
solíamos comprar muchas cosas con 100
liras ahora vamos al mercado escogemos
un par entregamos 100 liras y nos vamos
los precios están aumentando mucho
nuestro poder adquisitivo está
disminuyendo constantemente
juniors el instituto de estadísticas de
turquía dice que la inflación anual de
precios al consumidor del país aumentó
al
36.08 por ciento en diciembre en
comparación con el 21.3 por ciento del
mes anterior el aumento fue impulsado
por la subida de los costos del
transporte alimentos y bebidas y las
importaciones la inflación ha ido
aumentando a medida que la liga turca se
desploma su valor frente al dólar
estadounidense cayó un 44% el año pasado
se culpa al presidente turco de reducir
los intereses de los préstamos para
impulsar el crecimiento a pesar de que
los economistas dicen que la forma de
controlar la inflación es subiendo las
tasas de interés en respuesta a las
cifras de inflación más altas and
arremetió contra las élites que según él
se han beneficiado de la crisis
mientras la nación perdía mientras
jubilados funcionarios trabajadores
gente de negocios comerciantes y
productores estaban perdiendo una
minoría de la élite que se ha
beneficiado de la crisis ha seguido
ganando floreciendo y aumentando su
riqueza
virgen edición hábil de la crisis
económica ha afectado la imagen de
erdogán en las encuestas antes de unas
difíciles elecciones que se esperan para
mediados de 2023 y en las que aspira a
un nuevo mandato así llegamos al final
de nuestras noticias pero ustedes sigan
conectados a la programación de france
[Música]